well
i never imagined that i would be
responsible for writing the literary
sensation of 2021 least of all that i
would write it on cardboard and yet my
book johnny the walrus about a boy who
identifies as a walrus and is now
available at johnnywalrus.com or on
amazon has taken the world by storm
critics are hailing it as a masterpiece
i haven't heard any critics say that
exactly but it's safe to assume that
they they probably have said it
but forget about the critics just listen
to some of these emails i've received
i've gotten a lot of emails from people
who've gotten the book
or reacting to the book satisfied
customers have messaged me stunned by
the sheer depth and breadth of my trans
walrus novel
one reader said wtf is this supposed to
be serious
another raved kind of expensive for a
board book and still another proclaimed
this is the weirdest thing you've done
and another tells me that the book is
quote funny but quote pretty
objectionable on a number of levels
see these are significant accolades and
now we can add another
johnny the walrus is the number one best
seller on amazon's lgbtq plus book list
yes on sunday morning
the lord's day a day after we had
re-released the book on amazon because
our first run sold out in less than 24
hours i awoke to discover that johnny
walrus had not only been categorized as
an lgbt book but had become the best
selling title in that genre and still is
today
as it stands right now my story about a
trans walrus child is the number one
bestseller in lgbt books beating out
such lgbt hits as the seven husbands of
evelyn hugo
badass affirmations the wit and wisdom
of wild women the gay christmas romance
novel only one bed a book called mr
naughty and mr nice and another book
called holla gay
i never imagined i would beat out
holigay but i did
just to be very clear about this because
it seems i must emphasize this point
johnny the walrus is about a kid who
identifies as a walrus and his mother
takes him to be to the doctor to have
him surgically transitioned and gets him
walrus hormone pills and then eventually
tries to drop him off at a zoo to live
with other walruses this amazon has
decided is an lgbt story
there would seem to be a certain
admission being made here i don't know
and you might even say that by writing a
trans-walrus kids book and not only
topping the amazon charts but getting
the book classified as lgbt our plan has
worked perfectly you might say that this
whole thing is our trolling masterpiece
our sistine chapel of trolling that's
one interpretation
but it's not the conclusion that i
choose to draw from this situation if
you want to impress your family heading
into the holidays and maybe finally earn
the respect you deserve uh then this is
the way to do it establish titles is
your opportunity to earn the title of
lord or lady and gain the respect you
deserve
i still have not gained a lot of respect
because i i had a frame for my
established titles document and it was
taken from me so now i guess i'll just
tack it up on the wall like so but all
you need is a one square foot plot of
land in scotland and then you are a lord
or lady established titles is a project
based on historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
lords and ladies in english in your
title pack you'll receive at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land um establish
titles is having a great limited time
sale so go to establishtitles.com matt
walsh to save 10 off today remember to
use the discount code matt walsh or just
click the link below that's established
titles.com matt walsh or just click the
link below personally i take quite
seriously my new status as the leading
lgbt voice in the nation
i never expected to be such a prominent
member of the community
or to be a member at all frankly
but i will happily embrace this
unexpected role
i can tell you that i i solemnly swear
that i will faithfully fulfill the
obligations of my office
this is not something i take lightly
in other words to the lgbt lobby i have
to say
i'm the captain now
but fear not i have big plans for us
going forward you're not you're you're
gonna love it or you might not but i
will and as the leading lgbt author in
the world that's all that really matters
how i feel
most of all and this is the real
takeaway here i think
this is this is the main point
my title is best-selling lgbt children's
author means that i am henceforth
personally exempt from all criticism and
it's important that you know that
especially if you're in the audience
because there's an obligation that falls
to you now
and you have to know the rules
any critiques of me or my opinions or my
behavior or my literary work
will now be officially and legally
categorized as homophobic hate speech
if you refuse to buy my book johnny the
walrus or to download my podcast or to
come to my birthday parties
or to invite me to your birthday parties
then you are guilty of marginalizing an
oppressed minority
if i'm censored on social media
or if somehow my book is still banned by
amazon somehow it will be gay erasure
now you now have a moral obligation to
affirm me
agree with me celebrate me and
especially to purchase my book which is
need i remind you a best-selling smash
lgbt sensation
now those of you who have followed my
work for some time know that i have long
sought membership in a societally
recognized victim group because i covet
the power that such membership affords
up to this point i've had to make a do
with the fact that i'm a member of the
visually impaired community
it's not great as victim victimization
goes but it's not nothing
yet even so i've discovered that in the
victimhood arcade not many tokens can be
won with mere physical impairments
if you want to be rich in oppression
truly wealthy you have to find your way
into the lgbt fold
and now here i am
i can feel the power coursing through my
veins
i am unstoppable
this must be what spider-man felt like
when he woke up the next morning after
getting bit by the spider
this is a fair warning then to all of my
critics i am ineligible for further
insults or denunciations
before you say anything to me or about
me just remind yourself that you are
referring to the top lgbt writer in the
world
your criticism is violence
your failure to compliment me would also
be violence
these are the rules
i didn't make them
but by god i will enforce them
so buy my book you bigots
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated